Clint is with us in Indianapolis hi
Clint how are you
hi Mr Ramsey thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
well I was wondering if you could set a
settle a disagreement between my wife
and I uh about six years ago
um our financial advisor
advised us to start using a cash rewards
credit card it's not one of the flight
miles or anything like that and buy
everything with that and we will get a
check about once every quarter
and my wife wants to go back to paying
everything with cash and not using your
credit card we're very disciplined we
pay the credit card off every month
um so I I think it's a pretty decent
deal where we get cash back what are
your thoughts
well she she tricked you
she led you into the cave where the bear
lives and asked you to ask the bear if
he was hungry that was unfair okay
she knew the answer brother before she
sent you to me so I'm gonna be nice okay
but here's the thing how old are you
I am 60. okay well you're you're not
about my age I'm 57 okay I remember and
you do two Green Stamps at the grocery
store do you remember greenstone I'm
sure oh yeah and um my mom would buy
crap at the grocery store that she did
not need so that she got more Green
Stamps
and that's how green stamp that's how
Green Stamps worked
and what we have found is there's tons
of studies on the behavior of a credit
card user and uh there's a thing in
credit card usage or in payment in the
payments world called friction
and uh anything that they can do for
instance Amazon Prime has low friction
you just push a button and stuff's
delivered to your door and you don't
even realize or feel emotionally that
you spent money the other thing that
they use in the payments world to
increase the use of a payments vehicle
like a credit card is a gamification
which is you get points or you get to
win the game if you play airline miles
points like you got Green Stamps in uh
in back in our childhood are all
gamification examples that direct and
cause behaviors they probably don't
direct or cause them that much for you
because you're a fairly disciplined
person
uh but to uh to assume that they don't
affect you at least one percent is
absurd they make money on you they make
money on you we know the behavior all
the MIT did a study that shows that when
people pay cash they spend 12 to 18
percent less on average I don't think
you're spending 12 to 18 more I think
you're more disciplined that but I can
just about assure you you're spending
more than one percent more and so uh
there's tons of documentations tons of
behavior analysis studies in this world
that show that while you feel like
you're making money on this at the end
of the week when all is added up you're
losing
and you're not losing by much not enough
to make you go bankrupt but you ask me
to solve the argument and I got tons of
data and logical thinking skills that
say that she wins the argument sorry
brother this is the Dave Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the Subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]